so hello everybody
uh today i'm going to to talk about
mainly about a
function layer so yeah i am jerome
rodder from the world from research
and here you see i tried to to follow
all the bad advice to to make a slide
you know like changing the font size and
striking stuff while it was just uh
to because yeah things changed recently
for the design of uh
this thing that was supposed to be first
name the net function
and finally it will be a this function
that function will be
an internal stuff which which would be
called function to net and the real
stuff would be
function layer okay and it's new in the
new version of mathematica
so actually before starting with a
function layer i would like to start
with a like an overview of what's you in
the new version for the
neural network framework so first we
continue efforts
that that some efforts that are already
started before
of stabilization and of big fixes
and it's of course to be continued
and we have extended several steps to
unlock
yeah more deep learning approaches so
things to train neural networks
so in the previous version it was netgun
operator
which was a a symbol to uh
which which which enabled to use
to train sorry uh generative adversarial
network in a user-friendly way
and then i think that the for the next
version the the same kind of stuff will
be the
to to make it easy for people to do a
reinforcement learning because for now
it's possible but
you really have to trick the framework
to do it so we would like to come up for
the next version of
similar stuff for as guns
but for reinforcements learning okay
and then uh so concerning the
extension of our framework to support
more and more
techniques of deep learning
so one thing is to train with uh random
numbers
so we have introduced a layer called
random
layer which can generate random numbers
so for example here
i generate i build a layer
asking to generate numbers following a
normal distribution
and i asked to generate three numbers
each time i am evaluating the the
network so you see the
this is a special layer that takes no no
input
sorry the the visual is a bit small here
but that's the the template
i cannot do anything about this uh
so yeah you see it it's randoms it
is simple sorry three numbers uh
following a gaussian distribution
and uh also we have extended the support
for integers in the new version like it
was
or a bit new in the last version that we
support integers and now
there is more and more support and
consistency on it
and with random layer you can also
generate so you don't see
maybe you don't hear but it's a layer
here that generates and this is also
here it's only vector of real numbers
but here this uh
this layer you see actually yeah i
forgot this here
not only generally and this is but here
you see that there is a an argument
actually
it's a function not a distribution that
i use to construct the layer
and it means that this layer will take
some inputs which will
give some parameters of the distribution
so in this case it's the maximum of uh
description uniform
distribution and for example uh
sorry i had the command here if i asked
to to generate an
integers between ten and hundred and
thousand
and ten hundred you see uh it's possible
with this kind of layers
uh there was also recently a
generalization of uh
draw powder the dropout here so it's
it's layer
uh very common for uh training to
improve generalization
uh during training neural networks and
it consists you've seen this stuff in in
uh
so basically the input was a random
matrix of random numbers
and then drop out just uh
apply a random mask and then the mask
values are turned off
to be zero you see here and what has
been introduced recently is that you can
before you had only this output but now
you can ask for the binary mask that was
used to produce this output
so it's also it's a similar stuff that
you could get with a random
layer and and for example a discrete
into
zero and one let's say right i do this
see i i do this to my random array layer
ah here yeah the thing is that the
output is not specified yeah that's the
special thing when that layer
has no output is that you have to
specify the
the output size sorry the copy paste is
not very
well working
if i want to generate three numbers okay
i can i could generate a matrix like
this
right if i put here so yeah this also
the size specification of the framework
for now
it didn't change like it's some simple
shape specification
right so yeah anyway it was apparent
this is to say that
what you have the binary mask here you
could get it with wonder malaria layer
but what is interesting here is the same
mask and in some approaches i won't
enter into the details but in some
papers it would be useful to
use the mask of dropouts to do something
else that there's
just a dropout okay there was some
several
uh generalization also of symbols or
renaming
like the for the encoding string so for
neural networks that process
text in natural language processing for
example
this was a this encoder so you see now
in the new version
it will say it will tell you that it's
been deprecated and renamed
so you've seen them before it was named
bp
subway tokens so yeah to quickly
to talk about this uh
this encoder is an encoder where you
pass a string
and uh yeah it it gives you indices
as output yeah it's it's a classical
stuff to to process
text but it cut the what is particular
is that it cut the text into sub words
which we cannot see in my example but
anyway uh
yeah to say about the extension that uh
now it's
server tokens and with the method bp so
you see before it was in the name now
it's it's only a method
and then let's see
yeah maybe it's not built in the
documentation because i'm working so yes
i'm working in things in the new version
that are
you know all the documentation is not
built
and in but the version or here there are
some bugs here and there
which would be sold of course in one
month
okay so uh yeah this is the new so this
is creating basically
the same subway tokens which has many
options
and uh with these encoders and with also
the extension of some
other layers uh some details here and
there we are able to import many models
so here is the page of the the models
specialized into text processing and you
will see that there is a lot of bay art
and gpt so these are the
for those who know deep learning on
natural language processing
yeah these are the last models who are
very fancy and
who are doing the buzz right there they
are able to generate text that is
similar to
to text written by a human and sometimes
with impressive
performance here so yeah for example so
if we look on this web page for
bert and ngpt you will see
that uh yeah there are many rights there
are only two in the previous version
and now we imported the more version and
actually yeah we
we did not like there are many more in
the literature of course
and we did not import all of them it
would be useless
uh i think so we try to focus on the
efficient one
uh so this is to say the one that
computes uh
the thing into a reasonable amount of
time because the problem with this kind
of model is that the
first one okay we are well performing
but
they were taking too much time to answer
and sometimes too much memory i took
too much capacity yeah
so yeah coming back to the new things
and now we are entering finally the
category of the
uh of this presentation with a similar
topic
which is presented by mateo just after
me uh which is compile layer so the
goal of compiler is to compile any wall
from
language code into a mxnet neural
network
and mxnet is actually the core uh at the
core
of our framework for now like it's the
the main
third party tool that we are using maybe
we'll use uh others
in the future but for now uh it's the
main
and uh yeah it has the property that if
you can code your function into surplus
plus
then you can have a custom layer into
mxnet basically
and with the new version with 12.2 comes
also a lot of progress
in the compilation progress in the
combination
sorry project uh and so we took
advantage uh
also uh in the knowledge for framework
of this uh
advances and now you so we are
introducing compiler so
the first version will be a bit
experimental we will
tune the design and also the capacity of
automatic differentiation like is the
the the main uh it's the i think the
automatic
differentiation of the any function of
the language
like it's the goal of the end goal of
this
is that you can enter your function and
just it's compiling uh
into surplus plus into in surplus into a
max set and then we can use it
into our uh language and that
function layer is a bit at a different
level so it's also taking the wall from
a language call
so the input is a similar if not the
same to compile layer
but it will produce uh
it will use just layers of of our
framework
which are optimized to build the neural
network so the difference
is that compiled layer is in theory able
to compile the
more thing it should be about yeah
it will be able to compile more things
but it will be slower also so functional
layer will compile less things but more
efficiently
and of course in the future a function
layer will use the internally compiled
layer
when it's not able to to compile
something
so to do what it can do efficiently and
what it cannot do efficiently to do it
instead of failing basically
okay so we are going to talk anyway
about function layer uh
in the second part of the of this talk
and uh
yeah also it's a bit related to the net
function
project actually because by doing this
uh
yeah i i will tell again later that
we want to improve the consistency
between the language and the framework
right there has to be a translation
between this and this so
everything that you should be able to do
in the language we should be able to do
it with neural networks i'm talking
about sorry i'm talking maybe
about array processing so everything we
can do on arrays
operations we should be able to do it
with neural networks basically so yeah
uh yeah a new coat of paint so i mean
yeah we introduced new icons which are
uh so the first goal which
was that they are more expressive so
that the user can understand more
what is the network doing uh but in the
end
yeah we are also limited by the size so
sometimes we realize that we cannot
express too much
so another important point is that these
icons have to be
identifiable right you have to
easily distinguish one from the other so
yeah we are
tuning still tuning the the icons but
here here is a
an overview of the current state so for
example here you have a
uh yeah funny net uh from text
processing where
you have some convolution so you see
some window so
this one will change actually so you can
forget it but after you see that there
is a max so max is
is clearly written because it's a symbol
and it's small so
so easy then this is the catenate layer
wait maybe i try to to increase the size
to show you this part
uh wait
so i guess i have to end the
presentation mode
and to do this sorry about this
yeah let's put it like this okay so yeah
this is the catenate layer that takes
uh several arrays i stuck them together
then this is a
ramp non-linearity this this is not new
one the linear layer also
it is a success icon uh threading layer
yeah this one we
might change also and after you see uh
when when it's a system symbol
rest must you see it's reason and then
you you don't have to see given neural
networks right
this is the recurrence the recurrent
icons recurrence is when you take the
output of the
of the network at a given step no the
input at a given step and the output at
the previous step and then you combine
them so
it's represented here
this is a another example with an
imagenet
where you see also a lot of convolutions
and pulling
yeah there are also some conventions
like when you see some square it means
that there
there is some learnable parameters so
this is a convolution for example
with you see some weights and biases and
when it's a circle like this
it has no free parameters it is a
pulling layer
so both have the same icon but different
shape because uh
by by definition they do similar stuff
like you put the kernel on
on the image but one has learnable
parameters not the other
okay and then
another example with a uninitialized
graph
with some attention layer this is the
softmax also with the mathematical
formula
the zoom losses will change the color of
it
okay now i will demo a net function and
explain you the motivation at the same
time actually now it's a linear
there is no any article uh
structure in this presentation it's a
bit linear today
so first the motivation is to make
neural network easy to write right
so for example you read a paper and you
you want to implement the
intersection of our union stuff which is
a loss right
so yeah this because i think that users
were struggling with our framework
mostly to write loss functions
right because most of time layers
are commonly used right convolution
layer linear layer
lstm we have them in the framework all
the frameworks of them
there is no problem on this one but
sometimes it's more on structural
operations or
yeah doing do loops this kind of stuff
which will be complicated
anyway so we are speaking about net
function make it easy for the user so
uh yeah this function here i could
i i could write it like this right my
function so here i
i write what i see here if i if i didn't
mistake
uh so i defined the four coordinates
of each square so there should be eight
inputs and i have a function
and now i just have to add in front
function layer
and now i don't have a function i have a
special object called function layer
okay which has many inputs so yeah
because here it's much special
you see here for those who don't know
it's the slot syntax for
uh input of association
right so
a function layer these are my inputs and
it contains a net and i can visualize
actually the equivalent net graph
of this function here which is a bunch
of threading layers plugged together
actually you see
like one area is uh computed by taking
the four coordinates of a square and
doing the stuff
the secondary are the same the overlap
is
mixing this to square and then uh area
over you know just the division
basically
of the terms okay then yeah this was
just another example here of
another function okay where you can
define and you can see also that your
local variables your blocked variables
appears as
layer names we will introduce another
mechanism to do it
like it's a bit of a hack as steven
would say to do it like this uh
i think we will keep it as a convenience
like this
but we will also introduce a more uh
like maybe this notify symbol to say
okay here
i wanted to create a node because what
happens here
is that for example this
x here so yeah actually i i use x
several times so this is
what is misleading and why steven did
not like
and he called it a hack it's because
there was uh
two times
there was three times seven x
if i do it like this um
yeah sorry then it doesn't know
uh it was this one i think yeah
okay that graph
okay so you see this x1 here it's here
yeah boom
so it's taking the input and that's
after it's it's applying a pipeline of
stuff right an edge i mean
n plus one which cannot be uh just a
just a threading layer because of the
mean here or with a
not an element-wise operation and then
you see that
behind this x one here uh there is this
net chain of doing the nut chain
the tana sorry uh aggregation layer to
do the mean
and then doing the plus one okay
so now uh why yeah just uh to say
why not net function and function layer
why why is it better so i think the main
argument is that it's a combo package
you have two things inside you have a
net
and you have a function so you can trace
back the function the original function
and yeah represent reproducibility is
important in deep learning and it's
always uh
very difficult to to
to guarantee so i think that it's
important uh
to make objects like this that carry a
lot the history that
how how do how are they make right how
can we make them again right
if uh okay so uh
also yeah you have the net and you can
extract so actually you can
uh so here yeah i had this
iou net right which was actually a
function layer which is not a net
well it's that right in a layer but i
can convert it to that graph just with
by using that graph
uh and actually this is this is working
there for any layer like if you do a
net graph of linear layer you will see
on a graph
with the icon of the linear layer right
so that's a way to
to test the icons quickly
of the layers but you don't care because
you don't have to test okay
so yeah you can convert to another graph
and in some cases
uh some operation some simple operation
can be converted to a layer
and in this case uh so it's with net
extract and net right because if you
look at this net function it has two
parameters for now
the original function and the net right
so you can extract this net
and in some cases it's an graph in many
cases actually if your
function is complicated but imagine you
you want just the median
uh then yeah you have a function layer
but the net you see it's not a
graph it's a just an aggregation layer
with a median
and normally if things are not buggy uh
yeah the net will always give the same
results as the function or the symbol
right
they evaluate the same they evaluate the
same okay
sometimes it's faster this is still
interesting but i was surprised that
sometimes we can be faster than
bacteria operations uh
and but so you can never hit but you can
train
train your network with it it means that
it will be derivable
cetera so if for example here i create a
net that project some data into some
some spaces where i'm taking the median
right with this median net that
i constructed with a function name of
median
okay then i want the median to be close
to one so i had a loss to be
to minimize the absolute value of the
difference
between one and mediana
and then i could train this network
right
so yeah i could make my entire network
or or some pieces with function layer
like it's a normal piece of the neural
network
with all the methods working on them
let's initialize that extract
all the surgery functions also that i
won't have to
demo today okay
and so as i was saying here you can also
trace back the original function right
and so yes if you want suddenly to
compile not in
our language but in something else and
you have another compiling tool for
example in surplus plus
you can do this with the function
okay motivation number two
getting familiar with the wolfram
language
framework yeah for the users who do not
know
the neural networks framework uh but who
know the
the language like here here i'm
mapping you see some for example
normalizations
i'm calling on these functions here that
function
and extracting the the net graph or the
layer and you can see the equivalence
and so you can learn things you can say
okay standardized was finally the
normalization
layer with the scaling levels empty list
and aggregation level one
whoa no but yeah it
simplified the life but it's uh it's
always the two way around actually
because for me i i got to know the
wolfram language
by the neural network framework so in my
case it's helped me to
to check the language actually
so yeah there are many examples i'm
running out of time so maybe i will
rush for the end but you will have the
notebook
uh i haven't put it yet but it will be
on the
attached to the event so you have also
the distances
right so here yeah many
distances or where can all these
distances can be written as a neural
network
right and if it cannot today maybe it
can be in one day
look at the breaker this who produces a
yeah a beautiful article a neural
network
yes some structural operation also to
flatten transpose so yeah this is
i think useful for the regular user
for example first you know there is not
the first layer
to do first you have to do a part layer
specification one
so yeah it would be boring to look at
the documentation to
find this kind of things now net
function will help you to
to find this kind of stuff and to learn
better about the framework
hopefully so embeddings here there is
just a
unit vector who becomes a unique vector
layer
this one okay maybe i have to do the
part uh
if you do a part uh on some new regular
career maybe it's equivalent to some
embedding layers maybe you have to
do some hack in the future
to introduce more and more layers so
yeah of course not everything is uh
supported and you should have a
beautiful error message if it's not
supported
and we fix bugs and not supported stuff
little by little
and the third motivation is the third uh
it's the last one uh
i wanted to see it to quote so it's uh
yeah it's more for us as a uh
developers of welfare language to force
us to have a consistency between the
framework
and the language this i already said
right and i talked about extensions also
like this net function project it
boosted us a lot to extend the layers
like the aggregation layers now it can
before it could only support the
five first i think and now we introduce
the median the variance the standard
deviation the mean deviation the
interquartile range
and there are always some details like
for the millions you know that there are
there are uh several ways of computing
the median
uh yeah like the bias and the unbased
way so we we
yeah we had to take care of this kind of
stuff like right to give exact
the exam same result with a function and
with the neural network
okay i talked about randomness right
before so maybe uh
maybe i move back to presentation mode
for this
aesthetical part that will
that is close to the end so uh yeah here
i
so i use random variate right to uh to
here to add a random mask
yeah i just sample one value it's a gray
mask and i apply it to an image
i am showing it here if i sample three
values which are my uh
rgb so red green and blue colors
so here i generate a random mask that i
added to an image and after yeah i can
play i can
i can generate some lines of
of noise of color noise or
a salt and pepper or a noise
anyway all these depending on the shapes
i specify into my
random diet function
also random choice will work with a
function layer now
like we could see can we see the trick
here here maybe here i
i now have to increase the size sorry
about this
okay so yeah this is the icon for a
random array layer where i
it's a discrete uniform distribution so
you see i sample an integer between one
and three
which will be my choice right which
input i take
and then there is a threading layer with
uh
some which which statement
and then uh
maybe now it's a bit too big
then yeah if i call my layer 10 times so
yeah here i
uh actually yeah let's
take other values than just one two
three
but 7 10 and 13 okay so i'm asking
oh it's never talking 13 okay sometimes
okay it didn't look any firmly dispute
but maybe it is okay
yeah and it's a transition to speak
about
learnable arrays also here i show how to
do uh
how to automatically switch between
[Music]
the input an input and
learnable arrays right which here i
initialize sorry i'm going a bit fast
but i will come back to
just to show that here the input is one
two three
each time one two but i take randomly
numbers and i invert them with a an
array
you know a scalar sorry that i
initialize it to
minus a thousand so yeah and to do this
uh
yeah we introduced a new symbol called
net array which is actually an extension
of
a nutshell array there is a typo here
you see
sorry it's not ah it's
yeah i have to click on f1 i guess so
yeah netarray okay uh yeah it's also
used as the cherry to share array but
it's a symbolic representation of an
array
in the framework so basically
it can so it's the way to introduce
learnable parameter without using layers
in that function basically
so yeah time is running out so
you will have to check the documentation
of that array so the more
and also a constant array layer which
was badly named it
because it was an array that was can be
learned it's not constant actually
just constant in the sense that it's a
layer that has no input so
it's a layer that produces a constant
once is learned it's learned
but but this constantly it was confusing
so
anyway we renamed it to netara layer
because
actually when you when you call net
array net function it's
uh it it's
sorry converted into a netery layer
okay uh and there are also some
facilities uh
to debug with echo like if you put echo
in some functions it will
uh connect
this intermediate output to uh this
intermediate uh
value to an output so you see here i put
an echo on the sign
it's this one this echo then i put an
echo
on this expression here which is a mania
plus so i call it a plus
right because it calls us two arguments
you can put a label here so it is
an output with the name plus and then
the same for the tanash here
it's not put with the tanash
yeah and also uh yeah there is a
difference
where is it about yeah
for fixed array you can simply use this
right
so for example here is a function where
i have to
input i compute the dot product with a
third
vector which is fixed right
and i want so here i use net array with
a given initialization
but this net array means it's like this
one
but it can be learned so you see if i
convert to that graph
you have two net arrays here one
one as learning rate multiplier zero so
it's this one actually which is fixed
and the other has no particular learning
rate so
it's learnable and we can check by
extracting like this
here i extract at the place too so i
have here the
learning rate pretty place zero with the
constant value i gave
anyway i'm running out of time so i hope
you enjoyed my demo of
net function uh no it's not that
function i'm not used to it because it
was recently
so i hope you enjoyed my demo of
function layer and
invite you to follow the the
presentation of mateo now on a compiled
layer
thanks everybody